opioid deaths in america hitting a
record high jumping by 30 percent
more than 93 000 americans died from
drugs during the pandemic last year
experts say the spike is from powerful
synthetic opioids like street fentanyl
which border patrol warns is pouring
across the southern border
officials say they've seen a 226
spike in pounds of fentanyl seized this
year since 2018 and
greg the first time i read that number i
had to go back i mean 226 percent if we
care if we say that this
is a nationwide health crisis this
opioid crisis
what about the border it's crazy it is
absolutely crazy but first off
the car saying that the cause of death
is opioids is like saying the cause of
drowning is
water all right technically correct but
actually wrong
it completely eliminates how the water
was how the water was uh
introduced to the victim as opioid
prescriptions
go down and clamp down opioid overdoses
spike okay so because but they're badly
reported as opioid overdoses
when they're actually caused by street
fentanyl which is uh comes from china
through our border and it's mixed
without regard to dosage
so the cause of death is actually
accidental
because of the unknown dosage and these
are people that would if they could get
a prescription
whether it is whether they're doing it
recreationally or it's for cancer
or if it's for pain right it's none of
your business
it should be allowed because right now
you're driving people
to the street where they're gonna die
when the press reports this
it's only what's gonna happen it's just
like this what happens with gun control
okay you're gonna target
the lawful and the legal drug users when
you're cracking down on opioids it's
like saying okay there's increased
shootings in chicago
we need more gun control laws to target
the law abiding
so it's bs what you really need is
legalization of all opioids across the
board hand the power over to the
individual right
and and let them reliably figure out the
dosage there will be none of these
overdoses
it is almost it is so hard to find an
overdose from a prescription opioid
unless it was suicide
other than that people could control it
you when you go to buy cigarettes
you don't buy one cigarette that has the
power of a carton
you got a box of packs with 20 doses
you can manage it we have to introduce
that logic to these drugs
or you're going to see this number keep
going up unless china kills their
distributors which they want
and the crazy thing is there was
actually a drop in some of this stuff
because for a while during the covet
crisis
the fentanyl was blocked at least less
of it was coming in from china
and then some of the experts said the
minute it was flowing back into the
market people's resistance to it was so
low
that when they got some it was almost
automatically a death sentence i mean
emily fentanyl is it takes less than we
can probably see at this table
to kill us it's so true and you're right
this is a multi-factor issue and it
takes an administration who
gets it to combat it so recently the
white house nominated
or they established a physician they
sort of said this is a historical moment
that we're nominating that we have a
physician in place now to lead
the white house office against drug
control etc but we is he going to deal
with china is he going to take a hard
stance on china where
last year the dea assessed as they were
the primary source
of fentanyl across our border is he
going to work in concert with the dea
and local law enforcement and border
patrol or is it going to be defunded
is he going to name the crisis at the
border that involves the trans-narco
cartels
using human smuggling not only as a
shield for their multi-billion dollar
profit drug industry and also a
secondary industry
is he going to deal with the gangs and
the community violence that are using
these drugs as a currency like the list
goes on
and so i think i'm i'm afraid for how
the administration is viewing this and
we'll deal with this was essentially
checking a box oh look at us now where
we were making history and failing to
see the forest for the trees
to the detriment of these hundreds of
thousands of americans that are dying
and jesse to the history point of this i
mean covet was a crazy year
and a lot of people said the lockdowns
kept you from treatment from aaa
meetings from narc
meetings i mean from anything and people
felt so scared and anxious and isolated
had to contribute we made a deal with
the devil so
our politicians sent factories and jobs
for the chinese and they sent us back
cash
but also death they have the
synthetics in china they ship them over
arrives at port in mexico the cartels
truck them up to the labs
and they cook it into fentanyl which two
micrograms
can kill you so they smuggle it across
the border and then the mob distributes
it
to these gangs in all the inner cities
and it's like a bad acid trip
but instead of having a bad trip you're
dead and
you tell that to joe biden you say joe
your open borders policy
is killing people what are you going to
do about it and he calls you a racist
so all of his talk about the borders
closed you can say that's disinformation
that's killing people
so he really has one solution and it's
three things you take
the cartels you just you designate them
as
terrorist organizations you close the
border and you throw massive amounts of
tariffs at the chinese so they can't
just ship
unilaterally into our country like this
and
i'm sorry it's it's a very simple
solution but our politicians don't want
to do anything about that well and
jessica will
the bind administration take that hard
line with china
i think that they it's certainly on the
list with them and angela merkel
and joe biden were talking about it
yesterday they made it very clear both
of them said that they have exactly the
same stances about china
and russia i know that this is something
that was a priority issue
during the trump administration
something that joe biden talked about a
lot on the campaign trail especially
as he emphasized the conversations and
the connections that he's had with
everyday people we all know somebody
who has overdosed or somebody who knows
somebody i mean it's getting
unfortunately as prevalent as knowing
someone who has cancer and
we really need to make sure that we
control what's happening at the border
so i think it's
the two-prong problem there's obviously
that issue and then there's how we treat
these people
and we need to make it easier for
physicians who are responsible and have
gone to school
to prescribe them for people who really
need it but also to make sure that nurse
practitioners and other
health care professionals can treat
people with opioid addiction
and make sure that they can get what
they need and that is part of joe
biden's plan that in april came into
effect uh that they could make
more recommendations in terms of opioid
treatments i've spent some time in west
virginia where they've had a terrible
time with this
and met kids who were orphans because
either both their parents have died for
it or someone's in jail and one's dead i
mean
there are ripple effects through
generations for this so we got to figure
it out
all right i have the solution yes we
have for a great solution let us let us
know if you would also legalize
uh let us know on twitter hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else